what is going on everybody welcome to
another python panda sentiment analysis
and finance video
in the last video what we were working
on was this automatic
moving average uh function where we
dynamically generated a moving average
calculation based on the number of
updates the company got now in this
video what we're going to do is we need
to formulate a strategy
for our trading and so i think the
one of the easier ways to formulate a
strategy is just to base it on the
moving average crossover so
if the shortest moving average is higher
than the second shortest is higher than
the third shortest is higher than the
longest or largest moving average
then that would be the most bullish
situation
and then from there we could we would
have less bullish um
scenarios all the way to bearish and
then we would want to sell
um so in the most bullish situation we
would want to buy four let's say by four
stocks
in a slightly bullish situation maybe we
want to buy three and so on
so that's what we're going to do first
and then after we've done that after
we've created this function
and because we can't really do this very
easily in pandas we can't make that kind
of an operation with pandas
what we're going to do is map that
function
to our panda's data frame and that's
going to allow us to be able to do this
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so the first thing that we're
going to do here
is we need to create this strategy
function so
i'm going to call this one define count
underscore
position and it's going to have uh four
parameters that's going to be ma1 ma2
ma3 and ma4 that we passed through here
and that's going to ask a bunch of
questions um if ma1 is greater than m2
is greater than a3 and then and so on
all the way down in a few different
combinations we could get
really huge with like a whole bunch of
combinations but for now let's keep it
kind of simple
now that said i don't really see any
educational value in making you guys
copy and paste well just copy
what i write because actually what i'd
rather have us do is just copy and paste
so writing all this out is kind of
pointless and a waste of my time and
your time and everyone's time
so what we're going to do is i'm just
going to put i'm going to copy and paste
this myself and then i'm also going to
copy and paste it in the description of
the video
so that way we don't have to waste a
bunch of time typing all this out
there's no point
so i'll put that in this in the
description of the video so
if it's not there someone remind me and
i will get it added
to the description as soon as possible
because i like to forget these things
so anyway so what this function does is
as we pass through the moving averages
it basically just
asks what is the case and if
there is no case it just returns a zero
and but if there is a case it returns
you know these numbers now eventually we
might have a return like
none or something like that so it's not
a number but for now we'll just leave it
zero
and anyway we just don't have that many
uh options here
i'm really thinking we probably should
return none
but we'll see about that anyway um
because probably yeah we'll have a
return none i think for now
and we'll see that might cause problems
down the road but we'll have us return
none if it's not one of these because
there's
obviously a lot more combinations than
what we've shown and what we're going to
end up doing down the
line is ask what's the difference
between the two numbers and that's how
many stock we need to move
anyway um enough on that
now that we've created this function
what we have to do is we have to map
this function to our pandas data frame
so we're going to use map to do
to do just that so once you so once
we've copy and pasted that we need to
come down to single stock auto moving
average
and underneath df equals df from
starting point onward
that's where we need to map this because
we can't ask these questions
without these numbers right so before
the starting point
ma4 doesn't is even like a legitimate
number so
we have to do it after this point so
once we've come to that point what we
want to do
is we're going to i guess we can also
we're going to have like a bunch
of a bunch of columns here
at this point so let's go ahead and get
rid of the original moving average
columns there's really no point for them
right now
so we'll do dell df
ma100 and we'll go ahead and delete the
other three
so copy that paste paste paste
250 500 and 5000
so we'll have those deleted now and once
you've deleted those now we're ready to
actually map this function
and the way that we're going to do that
is the following so we do df
pos for position and
we're going to say equals map and for
map we want to put in the function
that we're going to map so that's going
to be calc underscore uh
position and then we have to do comma
and now we put the parameters to this
function and that's going to be df
ma1 all the way to ma4 so i'm gonna
highlight that copy
paste space paste two three and
four okay so now that what that's gonna
do is it's gonna map the result or the
return
of this function at each step of the way
to the column df position
so that's all we do there and now just
to see that we did this we'll do
print df all the way to number 100
basically
and for now let's not plot anything so
i'm just going to comment this stuff out
here
and let's go ahead and run that so
hopefully that will give us
a position column that spits out the
number that we want
and then none will just be not a number
so when we go to calculate any
difference
um it won't calculate any difference so
we
it won't trigger a sale or a buy or
anything like that
so um wait for this to come up and
probably after that
we'll probably do that next part in the
next video
and here we do we do have our output
here
so this is just uh what do we do though
yeah the first 100 rows
and so here oh well this since it's
there's
so many columns basically it's down here
so i mean one two three four
and here we have not a number not a
number because this isn't these
you know this combination is not one of
the combinations that we chose
this is basically saying we want to be
at a negative one position
all the way through um at least for
these 100 rows
so so that's what it did it created this
kong for us and basically we can use
this column to
actually start executing a trade based
on
um these stock prices here right at
these times and all that so
as you can see we can start actually
we're getting closer and closer to being
able to back test this strategy
without all the data that we need in
this data frame so anyways that's going
to conclude this video in the next video
what we're going to be doing is actually
calculating any difference and then from
that difference we will actually
calculate
the necessity for a trade and then when
we do that we can use the price at the
time to calculate the necessity for the
trade
or i mean the the trade and then also we
can calculate
our current
the current amount of stocks that we
have how much those stocks are worth in
total
how much cash we have and how much that
value of that stocks is plus how much
cash we have
and that gives us growth okay so
anyway what we're going to go ahead and
do is we'll continue that in the next
video if you guys have any questions or
comments feel free to leave those below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time